there are many ways to tell the story of
the sunken crown and my previous video
on the topic is just one of them the
crown was worn by a forgotten king who
ruled over a devout Kingdom the people
of which built their city and faith
around a great slumbering dragon but all
things come to an end and the tragic
fate of the sunken city makes for a
really powerful tale this video will
help you to craft your own story about
the city of the sanctum though if you
want to hear my story then prepare to
cry and click the link on the screen I
really recommend you watch that video
first I actually use some storytelling
talent rather than just read item
descriptions whereas in this video I'll
be exploring some really interesting
concepts that couldn't quite make it
into that video the dragon Talon tells
you the deep below the earth behind a
door locked from the inside is a
magnificent city built for a great
slumbering dragon after the rotten you
come across this curious statue that
warps you deeper into the black Gulch
this statue raises a lot of questions
for you
so let's question it by the way these
bevels around the edge of the video
indicate when I'm entering speculation
territory so firstly what is this statue
well it reminds you of the one in the
shrine of winter so why is it here as
well the design is curious there appear
to be three headless serpents spiraling
around it it reminds you of the serpents
in Dark Souls one perhaps they had their
heads removed to mask their identity all
that aside though it seems that these
statues appear to take you to the realms
of fallen kings and we'll be sure to
find one in the old iron cape and return
to the one in the shrine of winter for
the next two DLCs and secondly you think
where am i warping to so this seems
easily explained as the statues seem to
take you to a related location most
importantly though when are we warping
to you know what time period it's worth
wondering whether we're actually going
back in time or not but I think that
we're staying in the present after all
were going into a ruined Kingdom that
has been untouched for a long long time
once this was a great Kingdom but as the
eternal sanctum key states it is now
filled with devilish creatures that
ensure no trust
shall cause offense so what is our goal
here well as stated by from our job is
to retrieve Hendricks crowns this
implies one of two things one vendrick
had the crowns and lost them or two
vendrick toppled the kingdoms but
couldn't secure the crowns and I
personally believe the latter it seems
like vendrick succeeded in toppling
kingdoms such as this one but something
or someone stopped him from retrieving
the crowns of the Kings so to get to the
bottom of this let me take you back to
the city before it was destroyed long
ago there was a dragon sleeping in the
depths below the black Gulch people came
to worship Him and built a city around
him to worship his magnificence this was
a city built on faith and it shows the
bonfire warps almost all have reference
to prayer and focused souls tells us
that development of sorceries was
stunted in silver as they were
considered taboo the people were also
great craftsmen and this shows in the
architecture of the city as well as in
artifacts such as the puzzling sword the
Dragons name was sin and just as people
came to worship Him others came to covet
him the drake blood knights according to
the drake blood great sword fresh dragon
blood was believed to be sacrosanct the
drake blood knights believed that by
bathing in the dragon's blood they could
become omniscient and transcend their
own existence the leader of the knights
was named york
according to York Speer York defeated
the sunken king who ruled over the city
and pierced sin the sleeping dragon in
order to claim his blood inside the
chest of sin you'll actually notice a
giant spear York spear butts in the
slumbering dragon immediately awoke when
York pierced him and from his wound
spewed forth a poisonous fog that
blanketed the city and death joerger
disappeared into the eternal sanctum and
nothing more was heard from the people
that worship the dragon so now your
question is who are the Drake blood
Knights well we know the drake blood
knights crave dragon blood and the
knowledge that comes with it this
reminds us of another one who craved
dragons and his name was vendrick king
of drangleic there are two conclusions
you
or from this firstly a lust for dragons
is something replicated amongst many
kingdoms in the souls games as dragons
are seen as creatures that hold answers
and this might just be because they were
the first beings on earth just as
vendrick decided to experiment and
create an ancient dragon to answer his
questions the drake blood knights could
have also come to the same conclusion
but decided to kill a dragon instead
theory number two and this is the theory
I choose to believe is that vendrick
could have sent the drake blood knights
to kill sin as he could have been
curious about dragons so this is
actually backed up in game when you look
at the ring of York who was the leader
of the drake blood knights this crest on
this ring resembles the drangleic crest
although it is a little bit blood we
find most drake blood knights within the
sanctum itself the area designed to
house the dragon the knights invaded the
Dragons home but when their leader woke
the dragon by stabbing him through the
chest the sanctum crumbled and the
knights were trapped within and there is
something sinister within the sanctum
with them the king is dead killed by
York the dragon is awake and escapes the
sanctum to sleep wherever he pleases in
this crumbled city but deep within
before the Dragons resting place is
Alana the squalid Queen so what do we
know about Alana while she is a squalid
Queen and squalid means extremely dirty
or unpleasant especially as a result of
poverty or neglect it can also mean a
lack of moral standards although this is
more of an aside she clearly represents
poverty filth and neglect even summoning
beings composed of muck and filth to
assist her she's very similar in
appearance to nashandra
who is the Dark Queen of drangleic and
it's likely she performs a similar role
in terms of bringing down the kingdom
her acts description reveals that she is
a fragment of Manus as long ago the
abyss dissipated but fragments remained
over time these fragments reformed in
ways that hinted at humanity's true
nature and I've looked over the DLC
notes and the description of Alana
states that she is gathering Souls from
the sleep
this is also hinted at by her soul which
says that she is slowly amassing souls
for the coming day of vengeance so what
day of vengeance would that be I believe
that the Queens are looking to get
revenge for the day their father was
destroyed long ago Manus father of the
abyss was destroyed by an undead who
seek to stop him from spreading his
darkness Manus dissipated into fragments
and we know these fragments formed into
the Queens the day of vengeance could
well be something that all the Queens
are craving so are the Queens working
together it's possible Ilana
guards a crown which according to
vendrick is needed to activate the
throne of want by activating the throne
of want we can link the fire anew which
is something that the Queens composed of
dark probably don't want also we are
being told that we are retrieving
bendrix crowns so it's likely that
vendrick knows about these Queens and if
he knows about the Queens then it could
be that they're working together that's
my take on it anyway
Ilana's most notable quote occurs when
you interrupt her singing for the first
time we were not worthy of the Maya what
does that mean a Maya is a stretch of
swampy or boggy ground which i think is
a reference to Alana's entire being she
exists in a kingdom that is decaying and
rotten and my most literal
interpretation of this phrase is that we
were not worthy of the Maya that she's
creating so she's going to kill us now
instead another interpretation of this
phrase is a bit deeper a Maya is a
complicated or unpleasant situation from
which it's difficult to extract yourself
as a queen of poverty she represents a
Maya and if we're not worthy of a Maya
it might indicate that she takes a
certain pride in being born of poverty
I'm reaching a bit if I try and carry
this any further but I think it's really
interesting to note the wordplay on
display another take on Alanna relates
to the rest of the law of the sunken
crown in general some believe that the
kingdom is entirely separate from
drangleic and that the queen is angry at
the drake blood knights for destroying
her Kingdom I tend to make a lot of
links to
because there are a lot of links but
also because it helps in fleshing out
the law of other characters like
vendrick and nashandra you can choose to
believe that the sunken city is entirely
separate from drangleic though and if
you want you could just think of the
sunken city as another cycle just like
vendrick had an evil queen the sunken
King had an evil queen just like
vendrick seeked the power of dragons so
too did the Drake blood Knights just
like nashandra pitted vendrick against
the Giants to ruin his kingdom Alanna
could have pitted the Drake blood
Knights against her own Kingdom there
are many valid ways of looking at things
so I really encourage you to do so but
next we should come to discuss NPCs the
first that comes to mind is the terrible
boss comprised of three NPCs wearing
really signature armor sets so one of
them Don's Luka Till's set and other
Don's Havel's and the third Don's Alvers
they actually mismatched these sets for
example I think Luka teal is wearing
bits of the thief's set and Alva is
wielding katanas so what's the deal with
these NPCs well I think they're meant to
represent the grave robbers of the
sunken Kingdom and it looks like they've
mismatched a bunch of legendary armors
along their journey and honestly to
think of any other possibilities is just
so law breaking that I'm not even going
to bother I mean these obviously aren't
the actual NPCs not gonna bother with
that one grave robbers are a part of the
DLCs environment and we find open chests
throughout the entire place another
notable thing is the discovery of
Flynn's ring so Flynn was an infamous
thief who utilized the power of the wind
even the most skilled warriors in the
land failed to capture him and his
presence or lack of it in the sunken
Kingdom is definitely noteworthy the
last NPC we find is Alana's mirrored
version of velstadt I simply think that
this is a replica of velstadt
as they'll start the actual one most
definitely resides in the crypt due to
his item descriptions my take on it is
that Alana must be aware of the Kings
hand they'll start and she takes it upon
herself to give herself a depraved
replica made up of Muk
slime some people think that it's rain
who is velh starts brother but I think
this makes little sense because he's
literally identical to the vel start we
see in the Crypt and RAM used a shield
emblazoned with a raven so now that
we've covered all the major plot points
of the DLC I want to delve into the most
interesting speculation that I've found
I think I'm going to have to keep the
border on permanently for all of these
they're super fun to think about but a
lot of it is speculation first the seven
deadly sins the seven deadly sins are a
set of Christian vices that have been
used in a wide range of media and some
like to think that they're being used in
the Dark Souls universe I kind of think
this is equal parts lame and equal parts
cool at the same time the sins are lust
gluttony greed sloth wrath envy and
pride and with the sunken crown DLC we
reason to believe that they might be
being used as defining characteristics
of the Queen's and even the wider cast
of characters in Dark Souls 2 so let's
match them vendrick describes nashandra
as a being of insatiable lust her entire
being is desire incarnate as she was the
fragment of Manus that precisely due to
its size was the first to restore its
form so basically her desire is
everything that she is and another word
for desire is lust in this case Alana's
soul describes her as a being of wrath
her dialogue is definitely more venomous
than her sisters and she is waiting for
the day of vengeance
so wrath fits Alana this leaves five
more sins so it's possible that we'll
meet another Queen who fits another sin
as the Queen's are supposedly the
fragments of Manas that represent
humanity's true form but this would
still leave a few sins so for the
purpose of speculation and fun I am just
going to fit the other sins two
characters seethe would be Envy as he
was envious of his immortal brothers the
serpents of Dark Souls 1 would be
gluttony as the serpent is a symbol of
gluttony gluttony can also be
interpreted as selfishness and the
Serpent's in Dark Souls 1 absolutely
manipulate the chosen undead to
and fill their own needs sin the
slumbering dragon could represent sloth
for obvious reasons as sloth means tired
sleepy lazy vendrick would be pride
which is the most original and most
deadly of the sins and it's also the
source of all the others he was obsessed
by a drangleic and his own power and he
was so obsessed that he failed to notice
what was going on around him and this is
an element of pride it also emphasizes
contempt for one's neighbor and vendrick
definitely had this he stole the crowns
from other kings and he invaded the land
of the Giants on the slightest
provocation
this leaves greed I can't think of many
characters to fit this so perhaps it's
the trait of another queen I don't
necessarily think these links are true
but it's interesting to think about at
the very least these traits definitely
exist inside the characters
personalities and that's just good for
storytelling reasons so yeah speaking of
Queens though at the end of my prepare
to cry episode I imply that the Emerald
Herald may well be our own queen my
reasoning for this is that every
previous king of drangleic appears to
have a queen that usurped their efforts
at the very end these queens are
fragments of manners and they're likely
taking a female form because dusk was
the last thing mana saw or captured
before he dissipated we the chosen
undead are someone who seeks to link the
fire just like vendrick was inclined to
so it's not that strange to imagine that
we could have a queen of our own and it
would be a pretty incredible twist to
the game if it were true there's a lot
going for this idea
it even ties into what I said about the
seven deadly sins what if the Emerald
Herald represents greed throughout the
entire game we're giving her souls in
order for her to power us up we know
that Alana is gathering Souls so what if
The Herald is doing the same with the
souls that we give her it's also
interesting to consider a lot of her
dialogue in a different context a lot of
it is really sinister I've probably
convinced a few of you to go and kill
her right now
but there's also a few arguments to be
made against The Herald most notably in
the law she is a child of the Dragon
this is said in the description of the
Aged feather
but also by The Herald herself for our
theory to be true she would a have to be
lying be not be a child of manners but
still be our queen because cycles
dictate that every king of light has one
or C maybe she's a child of the Dragon
but still a fragment of Manas somehow
there are definitely some links between
the dragons and the dark most notably
the dark diver Grand Isle uses a dragon
talisman with his dark hexes in the end
though sometimes there's real value to
be gained from simply thinking something
might be true rather than whether it's
actually true and that's why I dropped
this idea into the video let's finish by
talking about the dragons the ancient
dragon is worth talking about because
for whatever reason he has direct links
to sin the slumbering dragon of the DLC
the gigantic dragon has the soul of a
giant not the soul of an ancient dragon
he also resides in Althea's keep a place
where experimentation is a key theme in
the Eyrie we find links to sin that make
me think that sin came before the
ancient dragon so deep within we find a
petrified egg the description of which
states eggs are vessels that harbor life
itself and symbolize the deepest secrets
of existence but what does a petrified
egg harbor behind the egg is a mural
depicting an ancient civilization and
the dragon they worshiped this is a
mural also found deep within the sunken
city and it represents sin the
slumbering dragon if you take this
speculation as far as it goes you could
surmise that vendrick stole an egg from
the sleeping dragon and used it to help
him create his own dragon
you could also surmise that maybe the
mural didn't have its origin in the
depths and that maybe it's found
everywhere because it's really popular
I'm a bit stumped on this one so let me
know what do you think that's it though
to reiterate you should check out this
video if you haven't already I'm pretty
happy with it there's a great story to
be told in the sunken city so feel free
to rate the video let me know what you
thought follow me on patreon - I'll see
you later